today is about Justice
Justice for Nikki Allen and her family
Nikki was a seven-year-old girl who was
much loved by all who knew her
she had a whole life ahead of her
but on the evening of October 7 1992 her
future was cruelly taken away from her
we thank Nikki's family for their
patience and strength over the last 30
years
and our thoughts are very much with them
and continue to be so
David Boyd
hid his crime
lying about his involvement and
prolonging the family's suffering
knowing all along that he had taken the
life of their little girl
the investigation into Nikki's murder
has been one of the most complex and
comprehensive ever conducted by
northumbria police
I am extremely proud of the
investigative team
and all those who have played their part
in securing this conviction today
I further hope
this sends a strong message
that no matter how long ago an offense
takes place we will do everything we can
to ensure Justice is served
thank you
afternoon I am detecting superintendent
Lisa thika and I'm the senior
investigating officer in this case
Nikki Allen would have been 37 now and
who knows what her life could have been
her future was cruelly taken by David
Boyd who today is being convicted of her
murder
the pain and suffering that he has
caused and to so many people is a
measurable
this is a huge day for Nikki's family
and I would like to thank them for their
Incredible strength
after 30 years finally they have Justice